hey daniel espinosa expect a call from
Tony Scott's lawyers over the plagiarism
of directing Stiles probably won't
happen but it probably should safe house
safe house to me looked like a sure bet
it has denzel washington as this ex CIA
agent guy ex-cia agent guy it's hard to
say I guess who's like now a terrorist
or something you'd have Ryan Reynolds
who works for the CIA but he's like just
a desk jockey he sits around and doesn't
get in the action he's a rookie so after
the safe house is compromised Ryan
Reynolds has to escort Denzel Washington
to another safe house and I like that
concept which is pretty much my short
way of saying I like the trailer because
as that's going on you're like alright
this movie's pretty cool has a bit of
shaky-cam stuff that's making me ill but
you know it's alright and then it's like
halfway into this movie the filmmakers
were like oh alright well everything in
the trailer is now exhausted so what do
we do now I don't know just keep filming
and doing stuff the whole second half of
this movie felt like the writer was
writing the movie as they were filming
and the director was like alright yeah
I'll just run with that and the movie
became a bit of a mess I mean first of
all Denzel Washington the dude kills it
every time the guy is a great actor
never the weak link always brings it and
then you have Ryan Reynolds which I like
the fact that he wasn't his normal Ryan
Reynolds self he wasn't you know funny
or sarcastic or anything like that he
was normal I guess and he's one of those
hopefuls you know where he's like no
good prevails and you know we got to do
the right thing and I'm really boring
because of that I mean I understand he's
supposed to be the normal guy that we're
all supposed to connect with but he's
just the boring guy that we're supposed
to connect with but we really don't
think you have the action scenes half
the action scenes in safehouse were
really cool the other half were just
epilepsy when cars were chasing cars and
cars were crashing and wiping out it
looked really cool I was like yeah
that's a straight-up car wreck good job
on that
other times I was just like I can't keep
my stop mm-hmm all right stop moving I'm
watching the movie and I'm like oh yeah
I'm just watching stuff happen and I'm
probably not gonna remember this at all
now that I'm talking with you I remember
for the sake of this review my brain can
do that cuz it's tricky like that after
this camera shuts off won't remember the
movie I promise I mean the actors are
good the characters you don't relate to
the first half is pretty cool being that
it
to the trailer and the second half is
just a sloppy mess half the action
scenes are good and that realistic kind
of way and the other half you don't even
see because the camera is just doing
this in the end safe house is okay but
you're not gonna remember it in t-minus
one day what was that movie again so
this is the immortal question that must
be asked in a Denzel Washington review
what is your favorite Denzel Washington
role that he is done whatever it is
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]